[Musique]
c'est au palais de la source que le
conseil départemental des jeunes a
décidé d'organiser une matinée de
sensibilisation plus particulièrement
sur les cyclomotoristes avec le
partenaire de la sécurité routière et en
présence des forces de l'ordre
notre rôle forces de mort n'est pas
particulièrement un gendarme en c2
d'investir aussi sur l'avenir en matière
de prévention et de sensibilisation et
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire au
travers de mon intervention où on essaye
de sensibiliser les jeunes aux risques
routiers particulièrement sur les
principaux vecteurs d'accidents qui sont
mal connus l'alcoolisation excessive la
conduite sous à mal les excès de vitesse
et aussi le non port des équipements de
sécurité pour les d'euros pour cette
quatrième année consécutive
l'objectif est de revoir les différentes
thématiques alcool les deux roues et des
passagers et piétons est également de
sensibiliser ces jeunes sur les engins
sans moteurs
le département participe à saturne est
simplement
en investissant en fait les jeunes donc
les délégués au sein du conseil
départemental des jeunes sur cette
matinée de sensibilisation pour
qu'ensuite on puisse passer le message
au sein de leur collège partenaires il
ya des présidents de
comme la maille par exemple des
présidentes de mutuelle et il ya aussi
la police nationale et la gendarmerie
conscient de la gravité de la situation
la thématique sécurité routière reste
une préoccupation essentielle des élus
du cmj
[Musique]